la proximité de l'île de la réunion et
de l'île maurice permet de nombreux
échanges dans les deux sens des espèces
sont venus s'installer sur l'île depuis
maurice mais d'autres ont migré de la
réunion vers l'île soeur les deux ils
ont en commun un certain nombre
d'espèces endémiques
parmi celles ci le bois de perroquets se
rencontre partout sur l'île de la
réunion à partir de 800 m pourvu que
l'humidité soit suffisante
ils poussent rapidement droit à la
recherche de la lumière
dès qu'il est suffisamment haut il
développe deux grandes branches presque
horizontal
occupant les espaces vides du sous-bois
les branches et les rats mire porte les
cicatrices des larges la tâche des
feuilles celles ci sont groupés au
sommet des ramilles porté par de longs
pétioles teinté de rouge
elles peuvent être assez grande et
atteindre plus de 30 cm de long pointu
au sommet le dessus des feuilles ellis
tandis que les nervures marque fortement
le dessous
les fleurs naissent à l'extrémité des
branches de petites tiges longue d'une
dizaine de centimètres portent des
petits flocons rosé
ce sont des fleurs au mal
les nombreuses étamines forme des
petites boules de pollen
plus loin porté par une autre branche
est parfois par là même quelque chose
passe presque inaperçue en tout cas à
nos yeux
de petit appendice de couleur blanc
crème se tordent au hasard émergeant de
coeur minuscule ce sont des fleurs
femelles elle porte de tout petits poils
sur lesquels les insectes dépose le
pollen prélevés sur les fleurs mâles est
attiré par l'odeur alléchante
les fruits issus de cette petite fleur
femelle insignifiante sont a contrario
étonnant ce sont des capsules verte de
12 à 14 mm de diamètre à trois lobes
garantie si on est sur le dos chaque
demi loeb porte une corde courbée vers
le haut et crochus vers l'intérieur
est ce ce qui lui a valu son nom de bois
de perroquets
chaque lobe renferme une grosse graine
de couleur brun sombre lisse brillante
et arrondies
emporté dans l'estomac d'un oiseau elle
germera plus loin facilement rapidement
et contribuera à boucler le cercle
étroit de ce fragile milieu